on this Memorial Day an effort is
underway to have the nation's highest
military award bestowed on an Air Force
sergeant killed in a controversial
operation in Afghanistan 16 years ago
national security correspondent Jennifer
Griffin has the story from the Pentagon
reminded at a Medal of Honor ceremony
last week the president honored Navy
SEAL Britz lubinski for his actions in
Afghanistan shortly after 9/11 a failed
attempt to set up an observation post
nearly 11,000 feet above sea level over
an area where al-qaeda fighters were
operating Air Force tech sergeant John
Chapman was among the seven US service
members killed that day after a series
of mistakes on what is now known as
Roberts Ridge Chapman was shot returning
to find Navy SEAL Neil Roberts who
slipped and fell out of their helicopter
initially thought to have been fatally
injured Chapman was left by the
retreating SEALs but appeared to fight
on alone
the Air Force which has not received a
Medal of Honor since Vietnam has been
pushing to award Chapman the nation's
highest medal for valor we know now from
those predator feeds that John Chapman
was not dead that he got back up he kept
fighting
he killed additional enemy forces for
years former Air Force secretary Deborah
James pushed for Chapman's Air Force
cross to be upgraded he paved the way
for a safe the safe entry of the
reinforcing forces that were coming in
to follow on to the battle new evidence
the result of improved technology and
analysis of images fed back from a drone
flying above the attack site suggests
that Chapman fought on for more than an
hour after the seals left him the Air
Force does not blame Team Leader Brits
lubinski I think he did his absolute
level best on the worst day of his life
former army Delta Force operator Jim
Reese was in the Operations Center in
Afghanistan watching the video live
being privy to those to those feeds that
I was privy to during the operation that
night
seeing someone shooting when those
Rangers are coming in
yes I believe Chapman was alive the
seals say they did not know Chapman was
alive when they retreated
I do believe chappy was fighting up
there his resiliency you know he
probably passed out initially came back
up what Chapman did was above and beyond
because he was the last one on that
mountain so you know as we say though I
be the lone survivor at the Pentagon
Jennifer Griffin Fox News